OK guys, good evening.
So today we're going to
talk about web components,
and all this chance
to create the future.
My name is Zeno Rocha.
Here's my Twitter.
If you want to
send any feedback,
you know, this talk sucks,
this talk is awesome,
if you have any questions,
just let me know.
Just ping me on Twitter, I'll be
more than happy to answer you.
And I'm from Brazil,
which is kind of crazy,
because I flew like 16 hours to
be here for a 15 minute talk.
[APPLAUSE]
And I'm extremely happy
to be here with you today.
It's just amazing to see
all those people together
to talk about web components
and discuss this new thing.
And today's basically
about those three things.
It's about how to
create your element,
it's about how to learn
how to create your element,
and it's about sharing your
element and all your work
to the world.
When I first started
learning web components
was in the beginning
of last year.
And I was learning
web components,
was pretty amazed
by it, but then
I saw those two talks
from Alex and Matthew,
and then this other talk from
Eric on Google I/O last year.
And I was completely amazed.
It's like, oh my god,
this thing is crazy.
Web component's crazy.
It's going to change everything.
I really need to
study this thing.
I was just like that guy,
exactly same feeling.
And I started learning
web components,
creating my new things.
But at that time, there
was no starter kit.
So there were a couple
tutorials to teach you
how to create your element,
but there was no starter kit--
something, some boilerplate
code, something like that,
that I could just jump in and
start creating my elements.
So since there was
no starter kit,
I decided to create our own.
So if you want to create your
element using Polymer nowadays,
you can just go to
github.com/webcomponents/polymer-boilerplate,
and we have this boilerplate
for you, which is great.
There's a lot of stuff
that you can use it.
If you want to use X-Tag, no
problem, we got you covered.
It's basically the same web
component but using X-Tag.
But if you don't want to
use any of those solutions,
you want to see how web
components will interact just
using plain JavaScript,
just vanilla JavaScript,
we got another one, which
is element boilerplate.
So those three repos, they tried
to solve the exact same problem
using those different solutions.
And you can just
go ahead, see it,
and decide which one is
better for your problem.
And what's included
in those boilerplates?
So we encourage a
set of best practice.
We really want you to share
elements on Bower, for example.
We want you to have
some Grunt tasks
that you can put your
live demos online.
We want some
lifecycle call backs,
which are pretty useful
when you're developing.
So these boilerplates contain
those kinds of things.
But, still, that's
not totally awesome,
because you go to GitHub,
you click on Fork,
and then you need
to make some edits.
You need to do some
find and replace
and comments to change
and create your element.
So we decided, hey, we
can automate this thing.
And we created a
Yeoman generator
that can automate even
more live for you.
So it's on
webcomponents/generator-element.
And let me show
you how it works.
So let me create a folder here.
It's going to be
called my element.
Nice.
And then you install it.
And after you install it
from NPM, all you need to do
is type yo element.
And we show you this little
awesome welcome thing
that I took like
three hours to create.
And then you have
this first question.
What do you want to use
to create your element?
You want Polymer,
you want X-Tag,
or you just want vanilla JS?
I just want Polymer.
My element will be
called my element.
Yeah, I want
lifecycle callbacks.
And in three seconds, you
have your element created.
Let's check.
What is this?
So it's just the element itself.
It's important Polymer.
They have the Polymer
definition here
and the lifecycle callbacks.
So this is pretty great.
But this is just the element.
I want to create a
repository on GitHub
that I can share with everybody
and contains my element.
If you type yo element
repo, then you've
got this awesome
welcome message.
And almost the
same questions, but
what's the GitHub
repository you want?
What's your GitHub user name?
What's the name of your element?
What's the description?
Life cycle callbacks?
Yes.
I want to some
useful Grunt tasks.
And then it generates
all the files for you.
It runs NPM install
and Bower install,
and then grabs all the
dependencies, and boom.
If I open this in Sublime, you
have the application loading
platform loading your element,
importing your element,
and now you have your element
with Bower and the node modules
already installed for you.
So this pretty great, right?
So it's so easy to create
your element nowadays.
So, OK, we got creating
elements covered.
So when we put together this
boilerplate, lots of people
started to create
their elements.
And they end up
doing crazy things.
So
One of the things
that people have
been doing-- so this
library is tracking.js.
It's a library created
by Eduardo Lundgren,
he works with me at Liferay.
And it's a library to do color
recognition and face detection.
And we thought, hey, what
if we wrap this library
into an element?
Wouldn't that be cool?
Yeah, probably.
So I got these PlayStation
controls here, I
have some colors,
magenta, cyan, other ones.
And I hope this works,
because this really
depends on the light.
So let's see how it goes.
No, you can turn
it on, no problem.
So, first.
Let's do some
changes in the code.
Let me explain to you
what is this about.
So I have a video, and
I'm extending this video
to create a video track.
So my element is video tracking.
I'm expanding it and
creating a new thing.
And I added two new attributes.
The first one is what,
what do you want to track?
I want to track a color.
And what's the color?
Well, the color is cyan.
Can you turn on
the lights, please?
So this is cyan.
I need to do it.
Oh, no.
Ooo.
Come on, that's awesome, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
All you need to do is this.
But, yeah, I don't
want to track colors.
I just want to track a human.
But what part of a
human do you want?
I want the frontal face.
The frontal face seems nice.
If I go here, and, ooo.
Ah, no.
Why zoom.
So it's here.
It's working.
[APPLAUSE]
Imagine how hard it will be
to create an element that
makes face detection, right?
Peter, can you
turn on the lights?
Yeah.
Because this next one
really depends on the light.
So another element
that we created
is the SF-HTML5 element,
which is pretty useful.
You're going to see
how useful it is.
So what we're doing here is
just importing platform JS.
We're importing the element,
some CSS for the demos.
And if I open this on
Firefox, it's just this.
OK, it's just this
CSS thing going on.
But if I turn off the lights.
Ooo.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
So what this element
is doing under the hood
is using the device
light API, which
has just landed on Firefox.
And we detect how much
light has in his room,
and then we do something.
In this case, it's just
doing some CSS changes.
So, yeah, it's so awesome.
You have all those
things, and people
started to create
amazing things, you know?
Today we saw a bunch
of crazy things
that people are doing
with web components.
But we needed to show to people
that those elements exist.
So we needed a place
to show elements.
We needed a place
for people to hey,
take a look this is what I
created using web components.
So we got some friends
together last year,
and we created this thing
called customelements.io.
I don't know if any of
you ever heard about it.
Has someone ever heard about it?
[APPLAUSE]
Oh, that's awesome.
So we created this back on
August, and it's been crazy.
There's almost 200
elements in this gallery,
more than 100,000 page views
on the website from all
over the world.
It's just one page on the
website, so yeah, it's nice.
And now people are able
to share their elements.
And we have a place
to put those things.
Because before that,
we had, like, where
should I place my element?
Should I put it on NPM, Bower,
or any other package manager?
And OK, Bower seems
like the best decision
to put your elements, right?
It's the front-end
package manager.
But how can you find web
components inside of Bower?
No, there's this huge
thing, ecosystem,
with lots of front end packages.
But you can't filter which
ones are really web components.
So we made this thing to
put elements into the world.
And how do you add
your element there?
It's pretty easy.
On your bower.json
file, all you need to do
is include the web components
keyword, th this one here.
When you include this keyword,
you register your package.
And then it will appear
on customelements.io.
So it's really, really easy.
So we know how to
create elements.
We know how to share them.
But how do you learn
about web components?
If there was no SF-HTML5 for
you, how would you learn?
What's the main reference
to learn web components?
Should I go to Polymer website?
Or should I go to X-Tag website?
Should I go to some blog
posts that I find on the web,
should I go to HTML5 Rocks,
what's the main reference
to learn web components?
So again, we got some
friends together,
friends like Addy Osmani, which
really helped in this project,
and lots of awesome guys that
talked here today and are doing
amazing stuff using
web components.
And we are really excited
to present this to you.
We have been working on this
project since last year,
and we decided to
choose this conference
to show it to you guys and
present for the first time.
And this project is
called WebComponents.org.
It's not available on
webcomponents.org now,
so if you want to
reach, you need
to reach
webcomponents.github.io.
You can blame the
guys' work from Google
that didn't set
up the domain yet.
But this place is what we
want to give to the community
to learn and to share
things about web components,
and gather best practices, all
articles about web components,
these packs of web
components, the browser
support, everything,
presentations.
We want to put content
there that people
can learn what
web components is.
And we want to put the
best content there.
So what's web
components all about?
It's about gathering
best practice, discussing
API implementations, like how
should I build a carousel?
So everybody will
start to building
their own carousel
elements, right?
So what's the best
way to build it?
We want to introduce
useful stuff,
like the Yeoman generator
or the boilerplates.
And we want to highlight
articles and talks
like those we have seen today.
So now that's it.
We got covered everything.
And before leaving
you, I just want
to say that the
best way to predict
the future is to create it.
And that's the exact same thing
that we are doing right now.
We are not just
waiting for someone
to create the future for us.
We are here to define how
web components will be.
We are here to define the
future of the web platform.
That's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
One quick thing.
Oh, the mic is off.
So the slides are
here, bit.ly/wc-slides.
And I got stickers.
You can find me
after Rob's talk,
and I can give
you some stickers.
See you guys.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
Thank you.